𝘐𝘯 𝘱𝘳𝘦𝘷𝘪𝘰𝘶𝘴 𝘷𝘪𝘥𝘦𝘰𝘴, 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘤𝘰𝘶𝘭𝘥 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘶𝘴 𝘳𝘦𝘯𝘰𝘷𝘢𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨
𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘴𝘬𝘦𝘵𝘤𝘩𝘺 𝘨𝘶𝘦𝘴𝘵 𝘩𝘰𝘶𝘴𝘦.
𝘕𝘦𝘸 𝘳𝘰𝘰𝘧.
𝘕𝘦𝘸 𝘴𝘵𝘳𝘶𝘤𝘵𝘶𝘳𝘦.
𝘕𝘦𝘸 𝘸𝘪𝘯𝘥𝘰𝘸𝘴, 𝘥𝘰𝘰𝘳𝘴, 𝘢 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘤𝘰𝘳𝘬 𝘪𝘯𝘴𝘶𝘭𝘢𝘵𝘪𝘰𝘯
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘸𝘰𝘰𝘥 𝘧𝘪𝘯𝘪𝘴𝘩𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘸𝘢𝘭𝘭𝘴.
𝘕𝘰𝘸, 𝘸𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘨𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰 𝘦𝘯𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘫𝘰𝘣
𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴 𝘴𝘦𝘢𝘴𝘰𝘯.
𝘞𝘦'𝘳𝘦 𝘱𝘶𝘵𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘪𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘧𝘭𝘰𝘰𝘳, 𝘸𝘦'𝘳𝘦 𝘨𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰
𝘮𝘢𝘬𝘦 𝘢 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘥𝘦𝘤𝘬 𝘰𝘶𝘵𝘴𝘪𝘥𝘦, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘰𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳 𝘴𝘮𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘥𝘦𝘵𝘢𝘪𝘭𝘴.
𝘞𝘦𝘭𝘤𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘵𝘰 𝘢 𝘯𝘦𝘸 𝘗𝘳𝘰𝘫𝘦𝘤𝘵 𝘒𝘢𝘮𝘱 𝘶𝘱𝘥𝘢𝘵𝘦.
- How do we look?
We look like a team, hey?
Mmhmm.
- Yeah!
We are going to put...
the floor in.
It's gonna be the same boards.
The exact same wood as the walls.
I'm curious for what that's going to look like.
Yeah, let's go!
All the little lats are in place, and we are
now ready to put the floorboards.
Okay, so we cutted this piece.
Now, we are going to try if it fits.
Now that the floor has been sanded really smoothly, it's time
for one of the last jobs, to finish the interior.
And, that's painting the floor.
𝘕𝘰𝘸 𝘵𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘸𝘦 𝘩𝘢𝘷𝘦 𝘱𝘢𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘧𝘭𝘰𝘰𝘳, 𝘸𝘦 𝘯𝘦𝘦𝘥
𝘵𝘰 𝘸𝘢𝘪𝘵 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘢 𝘣𝘪𝘵, 𝘴𝘰 𝘪𝘵 𝘤𝘢𝘯 𝘥𝘳𝘺.
𝘐𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘮𝘦𝘢𝘯𝘵𝘪𝘮𝘦, 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘧𝘳𝘪𝘦𝘯𝘥𝘴 𝘰𝘧 𝘗𝘳𝘦𝘤𝘪𝘰𝘶𝘴 𝘗𝘭𝘢𝘴𝘵𝘪𝘤
𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘨𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰 𝘮𝘢𝘬𝘦 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘧𝘢𝘯𝘤𝘺 𝘴𝘰𝘤𝘬𝘦𝘵𝘴 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘶𝘴.
Hello!
My name is Joost!
The last months, I've been working on a redesign
of the Precious Plastic Injection Machine.
Today, I've got some shredded plastic, and I'm going to use it
to inject some into electric socket molds for Project Kamp.
Let's go!
The sockets have arrived, here at Project Kamp.
They look really awesome!
Look at all the different colors, and
different effects in there.
We really like to work with recycled materials
in Project Kamp, and especially, we like Precious Plastic.
Because, it's another project by One Army.
So, if you like all the Project Kamp stuff,
you'll probably also like Precious Plastic.
So, go check out the website.
There's so many colors in here!
Look at that!
Green and red, black...
All kinds of different plastic waste.
Precious Plastic already had the mold for these
sockets, but there was not really a need yet to make them, so...
Now that we can integrate them here in the
project, is really nice to have it, as a functional product.
We're actually really curious what you guys can come up with, to make
out of recycled plastic, and use here in Project Kamp.
Yellow with yellow...
This one is going to be on a switch, and then
we can use it to power our lights.
For the switches, we went with the
second hand ones.
We found these through the internet, in Porto.
Oh yeah!
It's working!
Now that all this inside stuff is finished,
we are continuing outside.
We're going to make a nice big veranda here,
which you can sit and enjoy the view, with morning coffee.
So, the first step will be to take away this
temporary one, to make some space.
What's happening, Martijn?
- Preparing the places, where the beams will
lay for the veranda.
So, here we're gonna have a little vertical,
standing on the granite.
And then along this line, we're gonna lay
the other beams, on some cement patches.
Along our granite wall, I've been cutting some holes,
and making flat spaces to receive the wooden beams.
I'm gonna make this bit of the beam a bit
more thin, so it slides in.
𝘚𝘰, 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴 𝘪𝘴 𝘩𝘰𝘸 𝘸𝘦'𝘳𝘦 𝘨𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰 𝘥𝘰 𝘪𝘵.
𝘍𝘪𝘳𝘴𝘵, 𝘸𝘦 𝘤𝘶𝘵 𝘶𝘱 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘱𝘢𝘳𝘵𝘴 𝘳𝘰𝘶𝘨𝘩𝘭𝘺, 𝘢𝘯𝘥
𝘸𝘦 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘥𝘰 𝘢 𝘱𝘳𝘦-𝘣𝘶𝘪𝘭𝘥.
𝘛𝘩𝘦𝘯, 𝘸𝘦 𝘮𝘢𝘳𝘬 𝘰𝘶𝘵 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘫𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘴, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘨𝘦𝘵
𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘦𝘹𝘢𝘤𝘵 𝘮𝘦𝘢𝘴𝘶𝘳𝘦𝘮𝘦𝘯𝘵𝘴.
𝘈𝘧𝘵𝘦𝘳 𝘵𝘩𝘢𝘵, 𝘸𝘦 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘥𝘪𝘴𝘢𝘴𝘴𝘦𝘮𝘣𝘭𝘦 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘴𝘵𝘳𝘶𝘤𝘵𝘶𝘳𝘦,
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘥𝘰 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘤𝘶𝘵𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨, 𝘴𝘢𝘯𝘥𝘪𝘯𝘨, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘰𝘪𝘭𝘪𝘯𝘨.
𝘍𝘪𝘯𝘢𝘭𝘭𝘺, 𝘸𝘦'𝘭𝘭 𝘱𝘶𝘵 𝘪𝘵 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘰𝘨𝘦𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳 𝘢𝘨𝘢𝘪𝘯,
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘩𝘰𝘱𝘦 𝘦𝘷𝘦𝘳𝘺𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘧𝘪𝘵𝘴.
𝘛𝘩𝘦 𝘷𝘦𝘳𝘢𝘯𝘥𝘢 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘴𝘪𝘵 𝘰𝘯 𝘧𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘴𝘶𝘱𝘱𝘰𝘳𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘱𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘴.
𝘛𝘩𝘦𝘴𝘦 𝘵𝘸𝘰 𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘦 𝘰𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘦𝘯𝘵𝘳𝘢𝘯𝘤𝘦, 𝘢 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘣𝘦𝘢𝘮
𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘦, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘴𝘪𝘵𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘰𝘯 𝘵𝘰𝘱 𝘰𝘧 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘨𝘳𝘢𝘯𝘪𝘵𝘦.
I got our little string here, which we will
now mark to define the final length of the beams.
It's not working?
- Did you plug it in?
Yeah, I plugged it in.
- Ah, yeah, I see.
There's only 10 percent battery left, so probably
Dave switched off the power.
This is the place, where our one of our main
posts is going to stand, and I'm gonna fill it with cement.
I've made a little wooden template, for the
concrete to go in.
There's two rods sticking out, and later we
will drill holes in the bottom of the hole, to connect it to the rod.
This is for the air bubbles?
- Yeah, to get the air out.
Fill all the little corners...
Our main post will stand here.
I'm making a level template, and I'm gonna
fill it in with cement.
I hope Charlie will not be mad at me
for using cement.
Okay, welcome to a new episode
of Project Kamp.
I set up a little string here, and to make
sure that the beams are not laying in the water.
So, here's a, like, I made a cement surface
here, in which the beams lay.
I'm gonna put in a granite block underneath
the beam, and at the same time level it up to the cord.
Although it's a very sunny day, we don't have
enough power yet to use power tools.
So, for now, hand tools.
But, we should be back online soon.
What are you doing?
- Using electricity.
Things back online?
- We're back online.
Wow!
You missed that spot...
Just in time, man!
For the last rays of sunlight.
Cheers, Martijn!
- Cheers.
Right on time...
So, for the stairs something like this.
Maybe a granite stone here?
This one?
- That looks like a good one!
This one.
We're going to mount a big beam here, which
is going to carry our stairs.
And then, into the sides of this big beam,
we're going to mount these smaller beams.
We're going to make a little cut-out which
is set, so they cannot wiggle.
And then on top of that, we'll place our steps.
It started raining, so we've moved our ''stairworks''
to the workshop.
Shou Sugi Ban.
It is a Japanese wood preserving technique.
It's already been mentioned a couple of times
in the YouTube comments, and I'm very curious about this.
It's about burning the surface of the wood,
which makes it harder to penetrate for fungus, and bugs.
So, it's more weatherproof.
Yeah, after after the burning, we will oil it.
I think we're gonna try linseed oil.
So, we are very wet, but uh...
Our beam is dry, so we're gonna put together the stairs.
We're almost finished!
We're ready for putting in the stove.
Yeah, this looks good!
- Wow...
Wow!
It's finished!
- Keep the fire burning, Martijn!
𝘐 𝘭𝘰𝘴𝘵 𝘢 𝘭𝘰𝘵 𝘰𝘧 𝘴𝘤𝘳𝘦𝘸𝘴, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘮𝘺 𝘱𝘰𝘤𝘬𝘦𝘵𝘴 𝘸𝘦𝘳𝘦 𝘭𝘦𝘢𝘬𝘪𝘯𝘨.
Are you working for the screw system, Julie?
- Yes.
I'm harvesting the screws.
- Harvesting screws?
𝘍𝘪𝘯𝘢𝘭 𝘴𝘵𝘦𝘱: 𝘤𝘭𝘦𝘢𝘯𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘶𝘱 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘳𝘶𝘣𝘣𝘭𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘰𝘶𝘯𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘩𝘰𝘶𝘴𝘦.
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘴𝘱𝘳𝘦𝘢𝘥𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘸𝘰𝘰𝘥 𝘤𝘩𝘪𝘱𝘴
𝘵𝘰 𝘮𝘢𝘬𝘦 𝘪𝘵 𝘭𝘰𝘰𝘬 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘭𝘦𝘴𝘴 𝘮𝘶𝘥𝘥𝘺.
𝘛𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘭𝘢𝘥𝘺, 𝘵𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘳𝘪𝘷𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘸𝘪𝘵𝘩 𝘙𝘪𝘵𝘢,
𝘪𝘴 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘯𝘦𝘪𝘨𝘩𝘣𝘰𝘳 𝘍𝘦𝘳𝘯𝘢𝘯𝘥𝘢.
𝘚𝘩𝘦 𝘪𝘴 𝘢 𝘳𝘦𝘢𝘭𝘭𝘺 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘸𝘰𝘮𝘢𝘯, 𝘸𝘩𝘰 𝘭𝘪𝘷𝘦𝘥 𝘪𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴
𝘤𝘰𝘯𝘴𝘵𝘳𝘶𝘤𝘵𝘪𝘰𝘯 𝘮𝘢𝘯𝘺 𝘺𝘦𝘢𝘳𝘴 𝘢𝘨𝘰.
𝘈𝘯𝘥 𝘸𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘷𝘦𝘳𝘺 𝘦𝘹𝘤𝘪𝘵𝘦𝘥 𝘵𝘰 𝘴𝘩𝘰𝘸 𝘩𝘦𝘳 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘳𝘦𝘴𝘶𝘭𝘵.
Photo! Photo!
Fernanda! Fernanda!
𝘞𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘶𝘴𝘦𝘥 𝘵𝘰 𝘣𝘦 𝘢 𝘳𝘶𝘪𝘯, 𝘪𝘴 𝘯𝘰𝘸 𝘢 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘤𝘰𝘻𝘺 𝘩𝘰𝘶𝘴𝘦.
𝘈 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘴𝘵𝘦𝘱 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘱𝘳𝘰𝘫𝘦𝘤𝘵.
𝘙𝘦𝘢𝘥𝘺 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘤𝘰𝘭𝘥 𝘸𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘳 𝘮𝘰𝘯𝘵𝘩𝘴.
𝘞𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘩𝘢𝘱𝘱𝘺 𝘸𝘪𝘵𝘩 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘳𝘦𝘴𝘶𝘭𝘵, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘷𝘦𝘳𝘢𝘯𝘥𝘢
𝘪𝘴 𝘢 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘴𝘱𝘰𝘵 𝘵𝘰 𝘦𝘯𝘥𝘶𝘳𝘦 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘷𝘪𝘦𝘸, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘸𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘳 𝘴𝘶𝘯.
𝘒𝘪𝘯𝘥 𝘰𝘧 𝘱𝘳𝘰𝘶𝘥 𝘰𝘧 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘩𝘢𝘳𝘥 𝘸𝘰𝘳𝘬 𝘵𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘩𝘢𝘴 𝘣𝘦𝘦𝘯 𝘥𝘰𝘯𝘦.
𝘐𝘧 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘭𝘪𝘬𝘦 𝘸𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘸𝘦 𝘥𝘰, 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘤𝘢𝘯 𝘴𝘶𝘱𝘱𝘰𝘳𝘵 𝘶𝘴 𝘰𝘯 𝘗𝘢𝘵𝘳𝘦𝘰𝘯.
𝘠𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘩𝘦𝘭𝘱 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘣𝘦 𝘳𝘦𝘢𝘭𝘭𝘺 𝘢𝘱𝘱𝘳𝘦𝘤𝘪𝘢𝘵𝘦𝘥.
𝘞𝘦 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘱𝘰𝘴𝘵 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘦𝘹𝘤𝘭𝘶𝘴𝘪𝘷𝘦 𝘗𝘢𝘵𝘳𝘦𝘰𝘯 𝘤𝘰𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘯𝘵
𝘥𝘶𝘳𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘸𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘳.
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘨𝘦𝘵 𝘰𝘯𝘦 𝘰𝘧 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘗𝘳𝘰𝘫𝘦𝘤𝘵 𝘒𝘢𝘮𝘱 𝘣𝘢𝘥𝘨𝘦𝘴.
𝘕𝘰𝘸, 𝘸𝘦 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘨𝘰𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰 𝘱𝘳𝘦𝘱𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘢 𝘯𝘪𝘤𝘦 𝘥𝘪𝘯𝘯𝘦𝘳,
𝘵𝘰 𝘤𝘦𝘭𝘦𝘣𝘳𝘢𝘵𝘦 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘦𝘯𝘥 𝘰𝘧 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘴𝘦𝘢𝘴𝘰𝘯.
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘢𝘭𝘭 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘩𝘢𝘳𝘥 𝘸𝘰𝘳𝘬 𝘵𝘩𝘢𝘵 𝘩𝘢𝘴 𝘣𝘦𝘦𝘯 𝘥𝘰𝘯𝘦.
𝘛𝘩𝘢𝘯𝘬𝘴 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘸𝘢𝘵𝘤𝘩𝘪𝘯𝘨!
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘴𝘰𝘰𝘯.
𝘐𝘵'𝘴 𝘣𝘦𝘦𝘯 𝘢𝘯 𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘯𝘴𝘦 𝘺𝘦𝘢𝘳, 𝘣𝘶𝘵 𝘸𝘦'𝘳𝘦 𝘩𝘢𝘱𝘱𝘺.
𝘔𝘢𝘯𝘺 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘯𝘨𝘴 𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘣𝘶𝘪𝘭𝘵 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘪𝘮𝘱𝘳𝘰𝘷𝘦𝘥.
𝘛𝘩𝘦 𝘮𝘢𝘪𝘯 𝘨𝘰𝘢𝘭 𝘸𝘢𝘴: 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴 𝘺𝘦𝘢𝘳, 𝘪𝘯𝘵𝘦𝘨𝘳𝘢𝘵𝘪𝘯𝘨
𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘱𝘦𝘰𝘱𝘭𝘦 𝘰𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘪𝘴 𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘭𝘢𝘯𝘥.
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘮𝘢𝘯𝘺 𝘤𝘢𝘮𝘦 𝘧𝘳𝘰𝘮 𝘥𝘪𝘧𝘧𝘦𝘳𝘦𝘯𝘵 𝘤𝘰𝘶𝘯𝘵𝘳𝘪𝘦𝘴, 𝘢𝘯𝘥
𝘣𝘢𝘤𝘬𝘨𝘳𝘰𝘶𝘯𝘥𝘴.
𝘈𝘯𝘥, 𝘩𝘦𝘭𝘱𝘦𝘥 𝘸𝘪𝘵𝘩 𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘪𝘳 𝘦𝘯𝘦𝘳𝘨𝘺, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘢𝘮𝘢𝘻𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘴𝘬𝘪𝘭𝘭𝘴.
𝘞𝘦 𝘴𝘩𝘢𝘳𝘦𝘥, 𝘸𝘰𝘳𝘬𝘦𝘥 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘦𝘯𝘫𝘰𝘺𝘦𝘥 𝘣𝘦𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘰𝘨𝘦𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳.
𝘉𝘶𝘵, 𝘵𝘩𝘦𝘳𝘦'𝘴 𝘴𝘵𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘢 𝘭𝘰𝘵 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘵𝘰 𝘥𝘰.
𝘞𝘦 𝘸𝘢𝘯𝘵 𝘵𝘰 𝘭𝘪𝘷𝘦 𝘪𝘯 𝘢 𝘮𝘰𝘳𝘦 𝘴𝘶𝘴𝘵𝘢𝘪𝘯𝘢𝘣𝘭𝘦 𝘸𝘢𝘺.
𝘈𝘥𝘷𝘢𝘯𝘤𝘦 𝘰𝘶𝘳 𝘬𝘯𝘰𝘸𝘭𝘦𝘥𝘨𝘦,
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘴𝘩𝘢𝘳𝘦 𝘪𝘵 𝘸𝘪𝘵𝘩 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘸𝘰𝘳𝘭𝘥.
𝘐𝘵'𝘴 𝘢 𝘭𝘰𝘯𝘨 𝘵𝘢𝘴𝘬 𝘢𝘩𝘦𝘢𝘥,
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘮𝘢𝘯𝘺 𝘤𝘩𝘢𝘭𝘭𝘦𝘯𝘨𝘦𝘴 𝘤𝘰𝘮𝘪𝘯𝘨.
𝘉𝘶𝘵 𝘧𝘪𝘳𝘴𝘵, 𝘸𝘦 𝘯𝘦𝘦𝘥 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘳𝘦𝘴𝘵.
𝘞𝘦 𝘯𝘰𝘸 𝘩𝘢𝘷𝘦 𝘢 𝘣𝘳𝘦𝘢𝘬 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘴𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘮𝘰𝘯𝘵𝘩𝘴 𝘵𝘰 𝘱𝘳𝘦𝘱𝘢𝘳𝘦,
𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘱𝘭𝘢𝘯 𝘵𝘩𝘦 𝘯𝘦𝘹𝘵 𝘴𝘦𝘢𝘴𝘰𝘯.
𝘝𝘪𝘥𝘦𝘰𝘴 𝘸𝘪𝘭𝘭 𝘤𝘰𝘮𝘦 𝘣𝘢𝘤𝘬 𝘪𝘯 𝘈𝘱𝘳𝘪𝘭, 𝘸𝘪𝘵𝘩 𝘮𝘢𝘯𝘺
𝘣𝘪𝘨 𝘯𝘦𝘸 𝘱𝘳𝘰𝘫𝘦𝘤𝘵𝘴, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘦𝘹𝘱𝘦𝘳𝘪𝘮𝘦𝘯𝘵𝘴.
𝘓𝘰𝘰𝘬𝘪𝘯𝘨 𝘧𝘰𝘳𝘸𝘢𝘳𝘥 𝘵𝘰 𝘪𝘵.
𝘓𝘦𝘵'𝘴 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘩𝘰𝘸 𝘪𝘵 𝘨𝘰𝘦𝘴!
𝘔𝘢𝘬𝘦 𝘴𝘶𝘳𝘦 𝘵𝘰 𝘴𝘶𝘣𝘴𝘤𝘳𝘪𝘣𝘦, 𝘴𝘰 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘥𝘰𝘯'𝘵 𝘮𝘪𝘴𝘴 𝘰𝘶𝘵.
𝘛𝘩𝘢𝘯𝘬𝘴 𝘧𝘰𝘳 𝘸𝘢𝘵𝘤𝘩𝘪𝘯𝘨!
𝘏𝘰𝘱𝘦 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘦𝘯𝘫𝘰𝘺𝘦𝘥, 𝘢𝘯𝘥 𝘴𝘦𝘦 𝘺𝘰𝘶 𝘯𝘦𝘹𝘵 𝘺𝘦𝘢𝘳!